هذا هو البروفيسور ساتوشي سيكيجوتشي ، إنه
يبني أسرع كمبيوتر عملاق
في العالم ، ويمكن أن يغير
كل شيء أليس هذا الأستاذ المناسب
، أنا آسف أقول ذلك مرة أخرى ، انتظر هذا
ليس هو
هذا ، هذا ليس هذا ، لا ، إنه فقط في
بوابة للحصول عليه  الوصول إلى الكمبيوتر العملاق
، حصلت عليه بوابة ، يعمل الأستاذ
في تسوكوبا هنا في
المعهد الوطني للعلوم الصناعية
المتقدمة والتكنولوجيا ، وهو في الطابق الثالث
والحوسبة الفائقة هي تخصصه
وسأبقى على قيد الحياة ، سأفعل ذلك في حياتك
علاوة على ذلك ،  طلب الحوسبة التي
تعطينا ما لا يقل عن مليون مرة خمسة إذا
كنت تستخدم واحدًا ليوم واحد ، فقد يستغرق الكمبيوتر المحمول
أو سطح المكتب 3000 سنة للقيام بنفس
المقدار من أجهزة الكمبيوتر العملاقة التي تم
استخدامها لتشغيل
عمليات محاكاة معقدة لتغير المناخ أعادت إنشاء الانفجار العظيم
ودماغ الفئران الذي أعطانا الهواتف
المحمولة البيانات الحاسمة لعلاج
الأمراض وحتى ساعد في ابتكار حفاضات ،
وهو كمبيوتر عملاق يسمى Watson ، وفاز حتى
بمليون دولار لحصوله على المركز الأول
في الاختبار الموجز ، Jeopardy ، ما
الذي سينفقونه عليه على أي حال
، يهدف مبنى Gucci الثاني
إلى أن يكون أسرع وأكثر ذكاءً
منهم جميعًا عند الانتهاء من LLL يضع اليابان
في طليعة تصميم الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي يقول إنه سيكون قادرًا  لتشغيل
البرامج التي تحاكي عمليات التفكير الشبيهة بالبشر ،
ستقوم بتحليل أطنان
وأطنان من كميات البيانات التي
قد تخيفها أجهزة الكمبيوتر الأخرى ، ومن ثم
يمكنها اتخاذ القرارات بناءً على
ما تعلمته من البيانات التي
ستساعد الذكاء الاصطناعي
والمستشفيات  إجراء تشخيصات أكثر دقة
، ستخلق سيارات بدون سائق أكثر أمانًا ،
إنها واحدة من تلك المواقف التي تكون فيها
الاحتمالات لا حصر لها ،
لذا سيستغرق بناؤها عامًا ونصف ،
وتخصص الحكومة
173 مليون دولار للمساعدة في
تحقيق النجاح  أن تكون
مستقرًا كبيرًا وآمنًا ، ما يقوله الله هنا ،
أفلا تجعلني من النوع الذي
تفضله
هنا مثل ساحة انتظار تتسع لـ
30 إلى 40 سيارة وهكذا  شاشة الشاشة
بينما قد تقول رجل ضحكة مكتومة ، كلبي
يهاجم سوكيياكي يمكن أن يصنع آخر ،
لكن لديه فأر فأر Samadhi
أقول لماذا لديه فأر
Ando قادم وأنا على
ما يرام ، حسنًا ، لا توجد شاشة حسنة
narakasura لا um عشاء
يفعل  إنه يحتوي على أي أضواء أكثر من ذلك الرجل المجنون
لا يعمل على الإطلاق ولكن حتى
لدينا للحصول على سوقنا يبدو أن هذا الكمبيوتر العملاق
سيأخذنا إلى المستقبل ولكن
هل يمكننا حقًا التنبؤ بما
سيبدو عليه هذا المستقبل هل سيكون سيارات طائرة
و  jet packs vamos casa de tener mucho
جوني جوني مفتوحة بعد معجزة ميغيل لا نوش
سانجانا للتحدث عن
بيانات خادم الاقتصاد لا تمنح العجين مهنة
Reducto
شكرًا جزيلاً
[موسيقى]